This lecture is going to be
very dependent upon the
PowerPoint
slides, because if I take the
time to draw the cycles on the
board,
we'd be here forever.
So I would say sit back and
relax because you
have the slides.
They're on the Web.
And try to focus on what the
take-home message is.
OK, but before we go on to
biogeochemical
cycles, I want to just briefly
review some of the things that
we
learned in the second lecture.
I got feedback from many of
you,
actually, on the things that
were difficult to understand
from that
lecture, and those are
important for understanding
these cycles.
And the
one thing that some people were
confused by was this anaerobic
respiration.
Remember, I drew this on the
board, and it showed a lot of
reduction reactions.
And I think that was confusing
for
some people,
so let's just go over that very
quickly.
You've learned
in Graham's lectures,
and in my lectures,
that aerobic
respiration,
respiration of organisms where
there is oxygen,
that oxygen is the terminal
electron receptor here in that
electron
transport chain and it's
reduced to water.
So in aerobic environments,
when organisms respire oxygen
it's
reduced to water.
If there's no oxygen around,
the organisms,
and in
this case it's always bacteria,
look for the next
thermodynamically
favorable electron acceptor.
And so, whatever is dominant in
that
environment and is most
thermodynamically favorable,
they'll
use.
So, the sulfate reducing
organisms use sulfate and reduce
to
H2S.
Denitrifying organisms use
nitrate and reduce it
to these forms of reduced
nitrate or reduce nitrogen.
And we talked about iron
bacteria Fe plus three,
and reduce it to
Fe plus two.
Some can use manganese,
etc.
Whatever's there,
and it's thermodynamically
favorable, they'll use.
OK, so that
clarifies that.
Some of the people said,
you kept talking about
symmetry.
You kept talking about
I didn't see any
symmetry, and in hindsight I
can understand why,
because I just
threw that out and I didn't
really point it out.
So what I was talking about was
as we went through these
processes, you
see here, these elements,
sulfate and nitrogen,
nitrate, are being
reduced.
There are other processes,
particularly chemosynthesis in
which
these reduced compounds,
here's H2S and ammonia are
being oxidized.
So
that's the symmetry that I was
talking about.
And if you didn't have that,
if all the organisms were
reducing things,
the whole system would run
down.
You have to have organisms that
are
also oxidizing things.
And that's a key component of
all of these,
or
not all of the biogeochemical
cycles, but particularly the
cycles
of nitrogen and sulfur,
which have this redox
chemistry.
So that's
the symmetry that I was talking
about.
OK, now so let's talk about how
we think about biogeochemical
cycles.
Can you see the slide in the
back?
Try to turn the lights off?
That
was a double question.
Can you see the slide in the
back?
Yes?
OK.
So this is a generic map of the
components of biogeochemical
cycles.
And we can think of the earth
as a giant chemical factory in
the sense
that has what we call
compartments,
or reservoirs,
or pools of
a particular element.
Or it might be water that we
are
analyzing, and then there are
fluxes between these pools.
So here's a
flux, an arrow.
So typically these are
diagrammed with boxes and arrows
connecting them.
And you don't have to use all
of these boxes.
It could be we are just looking
at land, atmosphere,
and ocean.
I
mean, you can construct
whatever model you want for
these.
And these
are just some useful conversion
factors for the amount of things
that we're going to have
flowing between these
compartments.
And
here, again,
this is something we defined
earlier when we were talking
about productivity.
The mean residence time of,
say, an element,
say, carbon in the terrestrial
biomass, is the pool size,
the
amount of carbon that's there
divided by the mean flux in or
out
of the pool,
OK?
It's exactly the same concept
we
talked about for carbon.
And then the fractional
turnover, one over
the mean residence time is
simply the fraction.
If we're talking
about carbon again in trees,
it's the fraction that's
removed
per unit time.
OK, so you can see that when we
talk
about mean residence time of an
element in one of these
reservoirs,
if the whole system is in a
steady state,
in other words,
if the amount
in a reservoir is changing,
the flux in is going to be the
same as the
flux out, right?
You know that.
Just like a bathtub,
if you have
water flowing in,
water flowing out,
the level will say the same if
the
flow rate and is the same as
the flow rate out.
But often in nature,
you don't have that exactly.
And if you don't,
the
size of these reservoirs is
either increasing or decreasing.
So when
you're analyzing these systems,
your most of the time trying to
get the
very rough estimate of mean
residence time.
So if the flow in
and the flow out isn't the
same, you can either average
them and use that
as your flux,
or you could define your
residence time with respect to
the flow in or the flow out.
So, these are just gross
approximations.
What we want to understand is
the residence time
thousands of years,
millions of years,
days, rough approximation.
And the other thing I want to
say before we go on,
is that all of
these cycles,
we're going to talk about them
element by element:
phosphorus, carbon,
whatever.
But they're all tightly coupled
in
the system.
And we'll bring that up again
later.
Before we go on,
let's
just look at the solar energy
budget, which is driving this
whole
system, mostly,
there is some geothermal
energy, energy from the
Earth's, the magma that is also
driving biogeochemical cycles.
But
the solar energy is the primary
driver.
And if you say that the total
energy from the sun is 100%,
it's that
energy that is used in
evaporation, and winds,
and photosynthesis that
is the important component
driving the cycles.
And you'll see that
photosynthesis is a tiny
fraction.
The energy that plants harvest
is a
tiny fraction of the total
energy that is driving the
Earth's system.
And yet, this photosynthesis,
which is the basis of the
biosphere, has
an enormous effect on the
conditions on Earth.
That's an interesting
nonlinearity of the system.
OK, so let's start
with the geological cycle,
which is the slowest moving,
people don't
even think of it as a cycle
because while we are on Earth we
don't see
rocks flying through,
well, sometimes you see rocks
in a
landslide or whatever,
but for the most part you don't
think
of rocks as cycling.
But they do.
And if they didn't,
the system would run down much
faster than it is.
And we've all
heard about plate tectonics,
that the surface of the Earth
is made up
of these plates that are slowly
shifting.
And when they shift you
have earthquakes,
like we've had recently a lot
of.
And also, you
have volcanic eruptions that
bring material from the inside
of the
Earth up to the surface and it
overflows.
And that's part of this
geological cycle.
So, here's a really
oversimplified,
when the geology professor in
our department saw that
ever showing this he had a
heart attack by how simplified
it is.
But
it's just so you get the idea.
When he started editing it,
there are so
many arrows you can never cope
with that.
But just get the idea.
There's geothermal energy
coming in from the inner core of
the Earth
where you have magma.
Think volcanic eruption,
lava, which
ultimately becomes surface
rocks.
And they're eroded by
weathering by
rain, and then elements from
that go into the soils.
Soils eventually
become sedimentary rocks.
We're talking over really,
really long
time periods,
which become metamorphic rocks.
Some of those
are uplifted,
and some of them are melted and
become magma.
But it is a cycle,
a very, very slow cycle.
In fact, somewhere I read
70%, you do not need to know
this.
This is not geology class.
But just
so you have an idea,
75% of the rocks now on the
surface of the
earth have been uplifted.
So it's almost as if the Earth
is,
on average, maybe halfway
through a cycle.
So, this erosion here,
and
weathering, as we talked about
last time is critical for making
nutrients available to the
biosphere.
And the force of this
weathering is incredibly
powerful.
One number that I found in one
textbook that I never knew
before is that Niagara Falls is
eroding at 3
feet per year.
The cusp of the falls from the
water
is moving back 3 feet per year.
That's fast.
Another little factoid
when I gave this lecture one
year, students asked what is
going to burn
out first on the Earth,
the sun or the geothermal
energy?
And of
course I had no idea.
This will be over someday.
The Earth is going
to be history because without
the sun and without the
geothermal
energy there's no source of
energy.
So I went to my colleagues in
this
department, Earth Atmosphere
and Planetary Sciences,
and said, which
is going to burn out first?
And they said,
roughly the same time.
And we have about 2 billion
years, so not to worry yet.
But it is, we are only here for
a period of time.
So, that's the
geologic cycle.
Now, let's move onto the water
cycle, and then we're
going to go through the element
cycles of nitrogen,
phosphorus, and
carbon.
But the water cycle is
obviously important in carrying
those elements through their
cycles.
And the cycle is actually
fairly
well understood.
I say fairly because not all of
these things,
when you're talking about
global averages of things it's
very difficult.
But the weather service is very
interested in the global water
cycle.
So there's been a lot of
study done.
So in terms of reservoirs,
these numbers in black
are the amounts of water in a
reservoir.
And the numbers in blue
are the number of fluxes
annually of the amounts of water
moving
from one to another.
So, there is a lot of water in
groundwater.
There's a lot of water in ice,
and there's a lot of water
in the oceans.
And there's very little water
in the atmosphere.
These are the annual fluxes.
So you can see,
if I animated this right,
so 111, these are in terms of
square kilometers of water,
that's a lot of
water.
So, 111 minus 71 gives you 40.
So that's the rainfall.
This is the evapotranspiration,
and the net result is 40,000
that is
flowing into the oceans.
And in the oceans,
here's the evaporation and
here's the rainfall going in
with just a net of 40 that's
transported
from the oceans to land.
So you have 40,000 going into
the oceans,
and 40,000 coming back,
fairly nicely balanced.
That's good.
And so, let's just use this as
an example to say,
what's the residence
time of water.
Let's just calculate this.
We can just approximate.
So the mean residence time is
equal to the pool size divided
by the
flux, right?
So what's the pool size?
Well, how much water
there in the ocean?
Thank you.
1.35 times 10^9.
And,
what's the flux?
Well, we have 425,000
evaporating and we have 40 going
here.
So, I
would add this and that so it's
balanced.
So, I would use 425.
4.25 times 105 equals just
roughly how many years?
3,000
years roughly.
So we would say the residence
time,
the average molecule,
the average water molecules
floating through
this system would spend on
average thousands of years in
the oceans
before it would evaporate and
get back into the system.
So you should
now think about what the
average residence time is,
for example,
in
the atmosphere.
And you can see when the pool
is very small relative
to the fluxes,
the residence time is going to
be very short,
right?
That's something to remember.
When the pool is huge relative
to the
fluxes, the residence time is
going to be very long.
So, you should
think about that as you go
through your notes.
But, in oceans,
the
residence time is thousands of
years in groundwater.
The residence time,
again, can be very long,
which is why we don't want to
contaminate our
groundwater because it's going
to take a really long time
to flush that through.
Lakes: the residence time is on
the
order of decades,
streams on the order of weeks,
and atmosphere I'll
let you calculate it and figure
it out.
OK, let's move on now to an
element cycle,
the global phosphorous cycle.
First of all, there's no redox
chemistry in the cycle.
That's important.
OK, that's the first
thing to remember.
And it's called a sedimentary
cycle
because there is no atmospheric
component.
There is essentially no
phosphorus in the atmosphere.
Everything in this field,
there's
always an exception.
There is something called
phosphine that
comes out of bogs that is
really interesting.
But it's not a huge amount,
so it doesn't really matter in
this
analysis.
And, let's look at it here.
We have a fair amount of
phosphorus in land plants.
And there's internal cycling
here.
We
have the mining of phosphorus
from rocks.
This is a fertilizer.
No, that's not a mine;
that's a house.
Sorry.
The mine is invisible.
Here's the mine.
So, the phosphorus is being
mined.
It's put on crops as
fertilizer.
The crops are eaten by
the people in the house,
and the phosphorus ends up in
sewage.
Even
if it's treated,
it ends up in the rivers,
and it ends up flowing
into the oceans.
And there's a little bit in
dust
transport here,
but if you look at this whole
system, it's basically
the phosphorous cycle is a
one-way flow to the oceans.
The only return
of the cycle is via the
sedimentary cycle where you go
from sediments.
Those are sedimentary rocks
until you go to mineable rock
and through uplifting.
And this is on geological
timescales.
So, on the earth today,
the global phosphorous cycle is
really not a cycle.
It's a one-way flow to the
oceans.
Well, it's a
cycle, but it's an extremely
unbalanced cycle because
eventually
this one will come back.
It cycles very rapidly in the
biota, internal
cycling in the ocean.
So, it comes in the river,
it's taken up by
phytoplankton,
they're eaten by zooplankton,
and then the phosphorus
is excreted or bacteria chew on
dead organisms
take up the phosphorous.
It's excreted as organic
phosphorous,
and it cycles rapidly through
this system.
OK.
So the other important feature
of this one way flow,
and also
humans have altered.
In other words,
humans are responsible for
this, basically,
one-way flow by mining the
phosphorus and putting it into
the
agricultural system.
OK, yeah, and there's the
return flux.
OK, moving on to the nitrogen
cycle, which is much more
complicated
because it is redox chemistry,
OK?
And, humans have also had a
major, major,
major effect on the global
nitrogen cycle.
So, let's
first look at the global
nitrogen transformation.
So this isn't a pools and
fluxes diagram.
This is a summary for you
of things you already know.
You already know this.
It just looks
different than what you learned
in the second lecture.
So let's just
go through it very quickly.
If we think of the compounds of
nitrogen
as being either reduced or
oxidized and we think of the
environment
where they might be found as
either being aerobic or oxic,
having
oxygen, or anaerobic,
anoxic, not having oxygen.
We can draw a schematic of
these processes that hopefully
makes good
sense.
If we start with organic
nitrogen, but say it's a dead
whale
that you saw is organic
nitrogen, bacteria work on it,
and through
this process which you haven't
really learned about explicitly
at,
can convert that to free
ammonia.
That ammonia can be used in
chemosynthesis,
which you learned about.
OK, the specific type of
chemosynthesis is called
nitrification,
where this ammonia is
converted to nitrite.
Is that an oxidation or a
reduction?
Shout it
out.
Yes, yes.
It's an oxidation.
This was obvious because you
can
actually see the oxygen.
So, in that,
nitrite also in
chemosynthesis can be further
oxidized to nitrate.
And
chemosynthesis,
so this is an energy releasing
process for these
bacteria.
Now, so here we now have
nitrogen in an oxidized form,
and we
are in an anoxic environment,
and that should immediately
tell you,
oh, that's an electron acceptor
for the anaerobic bacteria which
are
going to dump their electrons
on this and convert it to NO or
N2O.
These are gases,
and nitrogen gas.
This is denitrification or
anaerobic
respiration,
which we already talked about.
And it also can be converted
through nitrogen fixation,
N2 gas can be converted to
ammonia.
We
already talked about this,
too.
Remember, bacteria and
cyanobacteria
are the only organisms that can
take nitrogen gas from the
atmosphere and
converted to ammonia for the
use of other organisms.
OK, and then
there's one other thing here
which is called assimilatory
nitrate
reduction.
And that is when organisms just
take up nitrate,
and
inside them,
and they reduce it so that they
can, they have to reduce
it to ammonia in order to
reduce it for protein synthesis.
So that's another route for
nitrate to become organic
nitrogen in an
oxidized environment.
So these are the important
biological
transformations in the cycle.
So, here's the cycle in all
of its complexity.
And redox is important.
That's a
feature.
I'm going to list these things,
and then we'll look at them
on the diagram,
has a gaseous phase,
in other words,
is an important
atmosphere component,
N2, NO, N2O,
and by the way,
this is a very
powerful greenhouse gas.
So, the balance or imbalance in
the
nitrogen cycle that results in
more or less N2O is very
important for
global climate regulation.
Nitrogen fixation by microbes
and
humans: very important.
And denitrification by microbes
is
the only way to return nitrogen
to the atmosphere.
If you didn't have
denitrification,
this process that you learned
in my second lecture
that you thought was just some
weird way things get through
life, is
incredibly important in
maintaining the global nitrogen
cycle.
So, let's look at this,
the details here.
So, in terms of nitrogen
fixation, that's taking N2 gas
and converting it to ammonia.
Biological fixation by plants,
or it's really not by plants.
It's by
the symbiotic microbes in their
roots is 140 times 1012 of grams
per
year.
The industrial electrician
fixation, that is,
what's done by
humans, there's a process
called the Haber process that's
incredibly
energy intensive.
It takes a lot of fossil fuel
to break that
nitrogen triple bond.
In other words,
to take nitrogen gas
and convert it to ammonia,
you have to break this triple
bond which is
very energy intensive.
But they figured that out
during World War II
basically, or was it World War
I?
Anyway, one of the wars,
how to
break that bond,
and that was the beginning of
the nitrogen
fertilizer industry.
So, this is human nitrogen
fixation
that is used to fertilize
crops.
So this is a huge fraction of
the
natural fixation.
I mean, this adds a huge amount
of nitrogen flux to
the system.
OK, in this flux here,
this is cultivated legume.
So, this
would be agricultural bean
plants that naturally have
nitrogen fixers
in them, and that also import
nitrogen into the system.
So, we consider that part of
the human flux.
OK, to balance this,
we
have denitrification,
which as I said is done by
microbes on land and
in the ocean.
So, looking at this,
is it balanced?
Is nitrogen
fixation on a global scale and
denitrification balanced?
Did I hear a no?
Which is greater?
Denitrification,
yeah.
If you add
this, this, and this,
you get 260.
Is that right?
Yeah, and then you
add this, this,
and this you get 310.
So, there's more nitrogen
going into the atmosphere than
we're taking out.
And people don't understand
this.
They think the denitrification
has
been disproportionately
stimulated by this huge flux of
nitrogen into
the system.
But this is an important
imbalance that a lot of
people are studying very hard.
OK, yeah.
That's the major feature that
you want to look at in the
system.
And
then, if we compare,
this figure is from your
textbook comparing the
biological nitrogen fixation.
Plus, lightning fixes it a
little bit.
Compared to the human,
you can see that humans are now
responsible for
an equal amount of nitrogen
flux on a global scale as the
natural
system.
This is a dramatic
perturbation,
and that's only in the
last 50 years or so,
dramatic perturbation to the
system.
This amount that we are doing
is, 140 gigatons is equivalent
to 10
million trucks of dry nitrogen
fertilizer that we are putting
into
the system with completely
unknown effects.
OK, the next series of
slides are just to illustrate
in one ecosystem the importance
of the
biota and maintaining nitrogen
in the ecosystem.
And I'll also just show you the
importance of experiments in
ecology.
And this is the Hubbard Brook
Experimental Forest,
which is
up in New Hampshire.
Some of you might have even
visited there.
This
was my first job as a graduate
student was actually working in
the
forest.
I was measuring phosphorous
concentrations in the streams.
And
what they do there,
just like that experimental
lake study I showed
you, here, they have permits
from the forest service to clear
cut
entire watersheds.
A watershed is just an area
that
collects the rainfall and
directs it into a single stream.
You can
collect the rain and measure
what's in it,
and you can collect the water
coming out and measure what's
in it.
And the difference is what the
ecosystem is actually doing.
So, what they did was they had
these two
watersheds that were the same,
and they clear cut one of them.
And
they asked with the influence
of this clear cutting was on the
quality of the water coming out
of the system.
And to make a long story very
short, it's a really fascinating
study
that's been going on for years
that I don't want to tell you
because
then you'll know how old I am.
But, here's the control
watershed, and
here's the water coming out of
the devegetated one,
showing massive
eflux of nitrate from the
system as well as other cations.
And your textbook does a
terrible job of not explaining
this.
And I
don't have time to go into the
details.
But, the major reason this
is lost, the vegetation is
really important in that,
but it's
important in also maintaining
the microbial community in the
soil.
And when it's cut down,
the microbial community
changes.
And
that is very important and
resulting in the loss.
It's a beautiful
study, which unfortunately we
don't have time to go into.
But if you're interested,
I can point you in the right
direction.
OK, now, let's go into the
really important,
well, they're all
important because they're all
coupled.
But this is the one that's
getting a lot of attention,
the global carbon cycle.
And it's
getting a lot of attention
because we have had an
incredibly
significant impact on it,
and we are worried about that
causing
major global warming.
And as an aside,
I'll just tell you
that I actually think the
global nitrogen cycle is a
sleeping giant,
and that the public doesn't
know much about that right now.
But in
the scientific community,
we know the perturbation we've
had on that
cycle could end up being
equally, if not more,
traumatic for the Earth's
climate as this.
But that's an aside.
So let's focus on this now.
So, here's the global carbon
cycle,
which you've seen now several
times in my lectures.
So here's gross
primary productivity,
and respiration by land plants,
respiration by the soils.
These are RA and RH that we
talked about
before.
And in this,
we have their balance,
roughly balanced,
and then
you have uptake by the oceans,
and loss of CO2 by the oceans.
Your textbook says this is all
a physical and chemical process
that's
absolutely wrong.
The biota are central to that,
and that's another
lecture.
But you already know that,
that the phytoplankton are
sucking a
lot of CO2 in through
photosynthesis.
So let's look at
the budget here.
And, this is the introduction
of CO2 into the
atmosphere by burning fossil
fuel, and the introduction of
CO2 into the
atmosphere by destruction of
vegetation.
So, we have 7.5 gigatons going
into the atmosphere due to human
perturbation.
The annual increase of CO2 in
the atmosphere is 3.5
gigatons.
So, 3.5 gigatons annual
increase, and,
let's see.
If we look at the difference
here between respiration and
photosynthesis we see that
there's 2 gigatons going into
the vegetation,
actually net into the
vegetation.
And if we look at this,
we see that
there's two going into the
ocean.
So, if we ask,
of all of this
anthropogenic CO2 where's it
going?
3.5 is going to increase in the
atmosphere.
Two is going to vegetation,
and two is
going to the ocean.
And it's this that we are very
concerned about because it's
causing a dramatic increase in
the CO2 in
the atmosphere.
Even though these are tiny
fluxes relative to the
global biological fluxes,
these tiny fluxes lead to a
significant
increase because the pool is so
small of CO2 in the atmosphere.
So, this is a trace of CO2
since 1960.
Here's a question for you to
think about.
I'm not going to answer it.
Its summer and winter
are out of phase in the
Northern and Southern
Hemisphere, why isn't this
just smooth?
This cycle that we see here is
an annual cycle of the Earth
breathing.
Remember I showed you that the
first lecture showing
photosynthesis greater than
respiration during the summer,
and
the reverse during the winter.
Think about why it isn't just
smooth
and canceled out by the two
hemispheres.
OK, and if we look at
that same graph,
this is atmospheric CO2 from
ice core data as a function
of time.
This is today,
and this is time before present
going backwards.
This is 450,000 years ago.
We can see that CO2 in the
atmosphere, and
this is measured in,
you take a deep ice core in
Greenland, or something,
and you measure the CO2
concentration at different
slices of
the core.
And it tells you what the Earth
was like back then.
And, this just dramatically
shows you what we are doing just
that the
last hundred years.
We have increased CO2 in the
atmosphere
dramatically by burning fossil
fuels.
And CO2 is a greenhouse gas,
and so we are very concerned
about that.
OK, this is just read showing
that slide from last time of
upwelling to
remind you that the
biogeochemical cycles of these
elements are tightly
coupled.
Remember, we talked about
nutrients, nitrogen,
phosphorus,
being upwelled from the deep
water, phytoplankton taking them
up,
drawing down CO2 and then we
had oxygen and CO2 going back
and forth in the water.
So, the oxygen cycle,
which we
haven't even talked about is
tightly coupled also to the CO2
cycle.
I'm
not going to show this there.
OK, moving on,
and I know this is quick,
but this is in your readings.
There is a newspaper article
about the
Biosphere 2 experiment which
now is pretty dated.
To make a long story
short, many years ago a very
rich person built the system out
in the
middle of the Arizona desert.
And it had seven ecosystems in
it.
It was sealed.
It was closed.
And, he put people in,
which were called
biospherians,
and the idea was to see whether
humans could create a
closed biosphere that would
sustain human life.
And, it was a miserable
failure, which is sad because
it costs a lot of money,
and has since
been taken over by Columbia
University to use it as an
experimental facility.
But the one thing that they
learned,
here's what happened.
They put the people in.
And it turned out that
there was not enough
photosynthesis to supply enough
oxygen for the
people to breathe.
Oxygen levels steadily went
down.
And the reason
for that, they learned later,
was that they had put way too
much rich
soil in the system.
So, the bacteria in the soil
were
sucking the oxygen out of the
atmosphere.
And they were
subsidizing the system with
rich soil so that people would
have
enough food.
But there was a puzzle,
because if this was the
case, because the cycles are
coupled, you should expect to
see
the same amount of,
if this oxygen is coming from
photosynthesis,
you
should see the same amount of
CO2 coming into the system.
And you should see an increase
in CO2 in the atmosphere.
And they
didn't.
In other words,
they saw oxygen going down,
but they didn't
see surplus CO2 in the
atmosphere.
And it took a bright graduate
student from Columbia
University to go in there and
figure out what was
going on.
And it turned out that,
so why didn't CO2 increase?
It
turned out that this CO2,
which was coming out of the
system from
respiration in the soil was
actually binding to the calcium
hydroxide in
the cement and making calcium
carbonate.
So, the cement,
another human invention,
was playing an important
role here.
The point is that none of this,
this is only understandable
in hindsight,
because it didn't work.
You can go in and figure out,
what the heck,
where did these imbalances come
from?
So, it was a
very interesting study,
and we learned that it's not
easy to mimic
natural biosphere on a very
small scale.
OK, I'm going to skip that one,
and come to this real quickly,
because
this was just on the news this
morning as I was driving into
work.
I thought, perfect for this
lecture.
The UN just announced this
millennium ecosystem
assessment.
It's on the web.
And 2,000 scientists have been
working on this for over ten
years
trying to assess the state of
the global ecosystems and their
capability to support future
generations, i.e.
you guys.
And
they say the next 50 years,
and those are the 50 years that
you guys
are in charge,
are absolutely critical for
whether or not these
systems will sustain,
be able to sustain human
populations.
So you
can go to the web if you're
interested in that.
OK, quickly to our civil and
environmental engineering major,
I'm
just going to say that our new
motto is nature,
tools, and toys,
that
nature is ecology.
There is a two series ecology
course.
Tools are
mechanics: basics,
fundamentals for analyzing
systems.
And toys is
design.
The part of the curriculum is
going to be designing
instrumentation for studying
environmental systems.
And there are these brochures
here and in the back.
So I encourage you
to pick those up if you're at
all interested in that major.
Now, let
me show you this cool clip.
Don't leave yet.
This is worth it.
It's
only two minutes,
and its nature at its best.
So, all I need to do here
is hit play.
And this is the soccer player's
look like this.
Oh, why
didn't that work.
myofauna are little bugs in the
sand.
That's my favorite part.
Life is a geological agent.
See, that would have been a
great
kick off for spring break,
but welcome back from spring
break.
All
right, I'll see you in a few
weeks.